cette photo de toi
me riant
je souris quand je vois
et c'est vrai
cette photo de toi
le son de ta voix
je cherche autour de moi
parce que je dis toujours ton nom
même si tu es là
mais ce n'est pas le cas  la même chose
que le son de ton nom
l'odeur de ta peau
il y a une place dans mon cœur que
je garde en premier pour toi
même si rapporte
tous les endroits où j'ai été
pour l'odeur de ta peau
je suis dans l'obscurité de la nuit
quand  je rêve si profondément
et je ne peux pas te trouver là-bas
alors je pleure mon sommeil
et je cours partout
pas de paix
cette photo de toi
m'aimant
je souris quand je vois
oh c'est vrai
cette photo ici
Et c'est bien vrai
cette photo de ton
étranger
hmm moi
euh